yeah so stressful morning oh no
getting in trouble
would you do it again was it that tasty
blooming good cake yeah i'll do it but
i'll do it clever next time i package
criminal cake i pay for it yeah
the life of a chess player yeah there's
a nice cake but you know
all right here we go game three magnus
eric and what are we seeing on the board
yeah it's a slow start to this game as
we saw eric arriving a bit late there
but it's transposed now into the queen's
gambit and a variation of the queen's
gambit declined that means that black
not taking one of the white pawns that
has been offered up early on and eric
going for a very solid variation i've
never seen eric use this opening have
you nope maybe he plays this opening
more in blitz online or in bullet chess
but um it's not his normal opening and
okay we did see a trade of pawns even a
trade of knights and it's a very similar
pawn structure to what we saw in the
last game so it's very grundfeld desk
the type of position looks like a
grindfeld but it's a different opening
and i'm thinking by linear dominguez one
of the very strongest american players
now
but yeah it's a solid choice for black
but if eric doesn't know the ins and
outs of it i'm scared for him yeah and
his match now against magnus another
move here yep just getting ready to
bring the black bishop out to a long
diagonal
very sensible both sides just developing
magnus will castle the white king now
eric you stand against quite the heart
attack there for a long time and you
deliver a good defensive game eventually
that strategy paid off but i don't think
it was because i played particularly
well so i definitely can't allow magnus
such favorable
positions in the next game
we had a tweet coming in here from
someone who watched your interview
earlier today and he kept messing up you
know you know his sister died and he had
to race raced her uh the day after the
his her death and he broke the world
record yeah he won it was a
incredible story suddenly no more
pressure nobody expects him to win this
game so maybe that's when the best
things happen and uh meanwhile a few
moves on the board simon do you
uh kind of are you revising your opinion
of black's opening just as we're about
to see a big pawn sacrifice actually i
don't like this opening for black i know
lots of strong players play it but it's
so tricky to defend this attack and
let's see what happens i'm sure now the
knight comes forwards as as we said and
then and magnus knows exactly what he's
doing the knight is heading towards the
black king um magnus on the attack um
critical moment then they will be tied
on points heading into the last day but
magnus he has uh he did win that match
against frags so indirect encounters
magnus will be on top of the table
actually and also duda will be only one
point behind loves to bring every piece
to the party but uh this one also looks
good i suppose sorry david i just seen
one other move as well i mean you could
move has he gone in with the rook he
looks like this okay wow i predicted it
simon wow for once i got it right so i
don't think he's going to take the pawn
near black's king though i think that's
not yet not yet maybe later yeah maybe
later yeah he's cleared another square
for his rook actually the two rooks
might team up on this line as well the
human just wouldn't okay and eric is
asking the question to magnus and
our guru david has predicted the right
move bishop takes knight on the board
yeah i mean it's also the nice trick if
you take the rook maybe we could just
show this as well there's one one more
variation uh okay um we can maybe
quickly show it yeah but then we see
these patterns working the knight now is
able to do what we call a fork winning
the queen so there's little patterns and
that's where you practice your tactics
they become second nature after all it's
a game of patterns you get used to them
you improve your tactics yeah and a
couple of moves but both sides just
improving their rooks classical chess
player yeah okay we have sorry okay yeah
i mean i'll let david go first i mean
with that one because
there's so many there's so i mean the
best or the one we prefer the best is
quite well it's up to you you can uh
maybe as well does that question mean
the best chess player in classical chess
or does it mean with a classical style
classical chess classical
day's work in my life
using the third rank to swing across and
go for the black king and okay i also
like magnus's move this is what we call
prophylaxis in chess is where you know
that checks are coming later so you get
ready for them you get out of the way in
advance you know what your opponent
wants to do later
the king just sitting on the edge of the
board nice and safe actually evacuating
the first rank where it had no
protection so magnus knows there's no
way to break through yet he's just
improving every single piece to the
maximum first also a bit stuck you have
to improve the black rook next to the
black king and there we go he stole the
words right out of my mouth he did
improve that rook sometimes i click on a
square when for example we have the
analysis board when i'm highlighting a
square
but then i'll drag to show the arrows
and the mixture between clicking and
dragging it doesn't sound like it should
affect things too much but the computer
has memory so if it's remembered you've
already clicked on a piece or clicked on
a square before and then you click on a
new piece sometimes it makes the move
for you so it's really weird but here
you've got the clicking you've got the
dragon it's a new thing but yeah we have
some more moves and and
i kind of like magnus's night maneuver
there dave but is it i yeah i agree
simon it's uh really creative i don't
think i would have come up with this one
because white's knight looked so
glorious in the middle of the board just
a couple of moves ago but passes on the
left hand side it can be very strong and
well okay eric not following your advice
he's actually traded rooks yeah i don't
like this the change in pawn structure
we mentioned white's pawn being really
strong earlier it's even stronger now
and actually maybe this is even better
than what i suggested keeping the rooks
on the board this second pair of rocks
for magnus eric on his screen he brought
his rook forward he kind of changed his
mind brought it back but then he did
make that move
and it looks desperate to me it looks
like he's trying to go for white central
pawn uh white's past pawn in the middle
of there but the black pieces that kind
of jumbled up and also it's allowed the
white knight to jump in
and that looks natural i mean look at
look at this horn move yeah and eric
doesn't play any of the top three
computer suggestions here we still see
them on our screen and the top computer
move as ivanka says crazy nobody in the
right mind will ever play this if black
had pushed his pawn in front of his king
we would have had to kind of uh check
the metro detector out and check eric
because this is so unnatural opening up
the black king when you're about to get
attacked anyway and the white knight
jumping in now the reason the king maybe
isn't so comfortable in the corner is
because it no longer protects this pawn
which it would have done if the king was
more centralized i'm not even sure okay
this has happened uh not sure of the
best square here or here but no matter
where she goes
it just looks terrible for black now
this queen is completely stuck black is
essentially playing with a passive queen
passive bishop um to be honest because
it gives you a tough position the
computers say it's okay but it's tough
to play a match between them and will be
in the lead eric running out of ideas
the black queen is stuck as we mentioned
the black bishop stark black's rook
can't really improve itself
oh nice
such a classy move sadistic before we
get to that move uh black's pawns just
weakened themselves that's why the
evaluation bar shot up in white's favor
but
i'm not as optimistic about that move as
you guys uh white's king stepping back
to defense and pawns because i don't
think the king's that well placed here
but either way yeah magnus is just
showing that he has the time he's just
playing with his food before he eats it
i think
you know he's just dangling it around
and just thinking don't play with your
food though magnus it can go wrong he's
just playing on the clock as well he's
just trying to play kind of nothing
moves to make eric a bit nervous yeah it
must have been because it was so
unexpected i was expecting all these
forward moves go forward with your rook
go forward with the queen uh instead
yeah you played with a flourish like
like like you suggested maybe with some
champagne as well little finger up in
there six seconds for eric he needs to
make a move okay he retreats his bishop
to allow the brooklyn though yeah it has
to allow the rook in i have to move
phenomenal idea will magnus see this
idea if he does it oh
it's on the board look at his camera
look at magnus's camera he was about to
play it okay well black finds another
move after i said it's the only move
just to explain as well simon why we
think it's so genius the queen would
have come across here white sacrifices a
rook but no matter where you go with the
king now uh literally any square you
move the king to it's checkmate on the
next turn
um the most obvious one is yeah he's
played it okay bring his knight back but
yeah he's brought his knight back to f5
hitting this pawn
overwhelming this square and remember if
the night is captured it's checkmate
we're about to see the game over i maybe
pushed the pawn forward and he has
so
magnus still has to
continue that night can go back where it
came from maybe
and it goes back
um oh but now maybe this queen takes
pawn yeah if the black queen takes the
white pawn in the center of the board
the white knight will retreat to the
center and the black rook is falling the
black rook is pinned the black grip
can't move because of the white queen
and
this game is at any moment
beautiful game for magnus as well i mean
i i think he
you don't even need to take the rook
immediately here you can you can
increase the pressure on that rook don't
rush into your decisions when you're
playing them uh but yeah magnus has
played very well in this game yeah
absolutely model game yeah eric i think
has got a sneaky idea in mind and there
we go magnus doesn't play the move we
thought doesn't put pressure on the
black brook and we have to jump in
because this game might still go for a
little while uh here i thought the white
rooks lighter cross we mentioned this
pin the black rook is uh indefensible
but the black bishop could suddenly leap
out pinning itself uh pinning this white
knight suddenly and after a few trades
we see that actually black might escape
into the end game we might have seen
this where okay white should be winning
uh this pawn eventually this is a
winning end game but a lot of hard work
to be done so magnus didn't go for that
he's going for the slow approach
defending his night now and after this
pawn push he's trying to win this
blackrook with his own pawn and uh this
is even more sadistic than the other
idea that we showed
eric has to block the pawn advance but
magnus now can win at will this pin is
never disappearing he will win the black
rook at his leisure what a move
that was by by magnus as well i mean uh
he's calculated that yeah he's just
three seconds two seconds one second
eric has to make the move did he make a
move has he moved in time eric it's
tight
he's lost on time it looks like oh no
worse kind of ending to the day for eric
hanson another win for magnus carlsen he
decides the match three points four
magnus carlsen